all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking up with the death
of loki yes we are
at one point along the line on this
channel we did siege on asgard
i don't remember what happened to that
video it's not on my channel anywhere
and i know you guys have brought it up
before and i know we did it i'm so
sure that we did it right but regardless
for whatever reason it's not there
anymore so we're recovering it uh and so
the idea here is see john asgard was
actually an event that's
long since coming and it actually kind
of concludes with this culmination of
this marvel 10-year run right and we've
talked about that before
when joe quesada came in and then just
reworked all of marvel's so basically
getting rid of the mirrors between
spider-man and mary jane watson
and having scarlet witch wipe out like
98 of the mutant population by removing
their powers and all that kind of good
stuff
what you got there was like this grand
reshuffling but one of the big events
that took place are really two big
events that took place
the first was civil war and the second
was secret invasion now the idea behind
civil wars most of you guys know it was
a civil war between the superhero
community
over superhuman registration it was a
huge event when it came out and even now
people still talk about it a lot of that
might be because of the movie but even
then
like i would say that before the movie
came out it was still a big talking
point among comic book fans but one of
the big things that came out of that is
that you saw tony stark
elevated to becoming the director of
shield but in the aftermath
of civil war you went into secret
invasions and secret invasion focused on
this story
where at one point along the line the
illuminati so like reed richards and
tony stark and and mr fantastic and all
those guys they'd all basically travel
to the empire of the scrolls just
because of the fact you had the cree
scroll war that impacted earth at one
point
and they basically told them if you ever
come back to earth will destroy you and
this led to the scrolls essentially
knocking them out copying their dna
and then sending them forward totally
unaware of what had happened and so the
result of this is that following that
time period the scrolls began copying
the dna of other superheroes and in
doing so we're secretly invading earth
this was an important thing because when
secret invasion came to light
tony stark was kicked out as director of
shield because he was viewed as inept
and then norman osborne basically used
some manipulation and then made himself
direct your shield
disbanded it and then created hammer and
that's where we kind of get into this
because what you end up having here is
norman osborne
really using a group called the ufos now
the ufos were largely incredible hulk
enemies at one point on the line they're
not super important here but the reason
why you have
all this happening and him meeting with
loki is because asgard
is the last bastion that when norman
osborne became director of shield he
basically dismantled it he created
hammer
and then he started working on this idea
of essentially making himself like a
ruler of the united states right to the
point that he would actually be able to
bypass the government in his current
form and they wouldn't have the power to
stop him right so he would kind of
capture everything
now all this is what we call dark rain
and dark rain was basically a branding
initiative it wasn't really an event so
he didn't have like dark rain part one
two three and four it was basically
the the marvel universe under the reign
of norman osborne which was a pretty
dark time a lot of the superheroes
basically bailed out right they walked
away they were like nope we're not
working for norman osborne and what he
ended up doing was replacing a lot of
the existing superheroes with villains
who were playing the roles of
superheroes but one of the things that
also happened is he had formed a kind of
inner circle which was called the cabal
and one of those people was loki and
loki had been working alongside norman
osborne since his return
at the start of j michael cerzinski's
thor run and his death following the
events of ragnarok
and so what had happened is that most of
the united states the continental u.s
was under the control of norman osborn
there were only two
areas that were not the first was asgard
because while it was located in brockton
oklahoma it actually hovered off the
ground a bit and so it technically
wasn't considered a u.s territory and
the other part was utopia which was the
island that the x-men had retreated to
off the coast of san francisco during
the events that we're leading up to and
as part of dark rain where they
basically bailed out on west chester new
york right what used to be the xavier
home for gifted youngsters
and so what osborne needed was a way to
essentially
launch an attack on asgard by making
asgard look like a credible threat and
so what he did is he essentially incited
a fight or incited a conflict with
wolfstag
and then had the ufos just detonate this
massive arena and the whole point behind
it was to make it look like
volstagg as one of the asgardians living
in the united states had basically done
it it was essentially a way to kind of
point the finger at the fact that the
asgardians do not belong on earth and
either they have to be conquered and
subjugated and put
under the control of norman osborne and
hammer or they have to leave and so by
virtue of having this bit of a catalyst
he initially starts sending forward what
we're essentially called the dark
avengers on a mission to more or less
take them out now
a lot of the guys you see here are
exceedingly familiar for example like
you see spider-man in his black outfit
that's not actually peter parker that's
matt gargan right that's the scorpion
who is undertaking that role at one
point you have classic hawkeye that's
not really hawkeye that's bullseye
that's kind of how this stuff went right
it was villains who were taking on the
role of heroes but what he basically
does is says
okay like we now have credible evidence
to show
that asgard is a threat against the
united states and her interest and as
the director of hammer it's my job
to protect the united states from it
from any credible threats so
we're going to attack asgard now a lot
of this actually kind of goes by way of
the white house right a big conversation
that takes place
between the uh the really the us
government at the very very top
having this kind of conversation over
whether or not this should be allowed to
happen now the biggest issue with this
is that the guys in the white house
are not a huge fan of this right a huge
fan of going to war with the asgardians
right and so much so that i mean you've
got like the
president and you've got like some of
the joint chiefs here and you've got the
secretary of state i mean you got some
heavy hitters here
right and and the president cannot get
through to norman osborne
like they literally like literally call
him up and it's just like like he well
he's not here right now
you can't talk to norman osborne it's
like why you know it's like like under
what authority does he have to ignore
the president of the united states and
then it's
norman osborne's authority and that's
one of the things where he immediately
makes an enemy out of the government and
the whole thing here is that if they go
to war with the asgardians the
asgardians just just the asgardians by
themselves would be more than enough to
crush the us military you add in any
other superheroes or or even
supervillains who side with asgard
against the us military or even just the
public perception of it the idea that uh
individuals that the us government is uh
attacking the kingdom of asgard that's
gonna turn things upside down so
on a just conflict avoidance scale this
is a big deal but it's also
a political scale in the sense of like
voters and all that kind of stuff but
the crazy thing about this is despite
all of that
norman osborne doesn't care and so he
basically sends all of his guys in
now anybody who's ever read siege will
basically tell you there's two heavy
hitters that norman osborne has here
the first one is the century robert
reynolds and the second one is
aries but one thing i do want to talk
about here is the iron patriot armor
of norman osborn at this point in time
tony stark's currently recovering and we
can cover that in a in a future story if
you guys are interested but the whole
thing behind this the importance behind
this
is that when norman osborne took over as
director of shield he took the iron like
literally stole the iron patriot armor
slapped it on and then had it you know
look the way that it does and then in
turn is like we're the avengers now
and in a lot of ways it was kind of well
received just because of
all the crazy things that had happened
in the world over time
and for the most part the the general
public doesn't really trust superheroes
in the traditional sense i mean they do
in so far as like they trust norman
osborne one because they don't really
know what's going on behind the scenes
and two because he's kind of ushering in
what he calls a kind of
you know new era or an order of peace
and people are receptive to that right
i mean people by and large will do
whatever it is aim to do in order to
keep things peaceful right even so far
as becoming apathetic no matter how bad
things get it's one of the things that
really kind of goes on here but when it
comes to the century and when it comes
to aries ares of course is the god of
war
that kind of speaks for itself the
century robert reynolds is a
hoss right this guy is is in immensely
powerful his powers are kind of waxed
and waned over the years in marvel
comics they've kind of made illusions
and and marvel's kind of painted this
picture that he can like alter reality
but we've never really seen him do it on
like a really significant scale instead
it's just one of these things where he's
like a superman analog
and he's exceedingly difficult to take
out now of course with all this going on
it's not as though you can just
you know one does not simply walk into
asgard right
and as soon as this invasion happened
there's thor right thor is immediately
taking everybody on but then you have
the century robert reynolds step in and
robert reynolds immediately starts
taking it to thor the ufo step in as
well but at the end of the day it'll all
come down to robert reynolds and thor
but while all that's happening
captain america is watching all this
unfold and it's just kind of like
no right this is not going to happen
captain america basically calls
everybody together and says
okay thor's currently down but he's not
out thor's an avenger we cannot leave
this guy in other asgardians balder and
so on we cannot leave them as the sole
defense for asgard against these forces
of norman osborne
they can't do it on their own and even
if they could they shouldn't have to
and that's the thing captain america is
like i don't care who put him in power i
don't care who did that if it was the
federal government or whatever but
basically all i see at this moment right
now is a madman right leading a march of
troops
into battle and i can't for the life of
me see why
because there is no real reason for it
to happen the the kind of idea here when
it came to asgard being put in broxton
and really the aftermath of civil war
this happened during sterzinski's run
originally asgard just sat on the ground
in brockton oklahoma it wasn't until
tony stark came came running up on thor
you know feeling a little big for his
britches and was like hey man you need
to register for superhuman registration
and thor beat him within an inch of his
life
well it was it was man it was man it was
it was the most amazing it would do it
was it was
it was hilarious regardless he beat the
hell out of iron man right like almost
beat him to death and iron man's like
okay fine fine fine then here's what
we'll do you lift brockson off the
ground it won't
necessarily be part of the united states
and then kind of go forward from there
you won't technically be on american
soil so you don't really have to follow
american laws but the whole thing is
that asgard was was
largely harmless right it was like you
stay away we stay away right don't come
over here and start anything and
everything will be fine and in a lot of
ways it was kind of a truce
again it's norman osborne setting things
up to basically secure asgard as part of
the last
holdout of his ability to kind of
conquer the us so to speak and so
captain america bringing everybody
together this is like
everybody right i mean you've got speed
you've got patriot you've got stature
i mean there's some heavy hitters here
man wicking can alter reality right this
kid just has an insane level of power
speed can run really fast rahu and then
you have luke cage of course bulletproof
skin i mean you've got like a roster
here right i mean just
a very a veritable just one-man arm like
this this is a team man
this isn't it's an avengers team man
from there things pop off
man now one of the big things that pops
off is aries comes to the realization
that norman osborne basically lied about
why it is there in asgard in the first
place now this is a thing to understand
about ares of the god of war right i
mean
he's usually a dick but like he's an
honorable guy right so it's one of these
things where like asgard
and and thor and all those guys they
earned their respective aries a long
time ago right like a long time ago
it's one of these kind of loose knit
bands right like ares thor
hercules i'm not aware they've ever had
like a comic under themselves
but the important thing here is aries
realizes he's been tricked and because
of his respect for uh for norman osborn
he's like no that's not gonna happen the
crazy thing is when he goes to attack
norman
robert reynolds steps in right the
century steps in and basically just
starts pummeling this guy right and
that's where you get like this massive
fight between the two but despite the
capabilities of ares as the god of war
he can't really do anything against the
century the century's on just
a whole different level i mean he
literally grabs him and rips him in half
and that's just that insane moment it's
like oh my god when this happened
and the century killed aries god of war
you immediately knew
something was off right like you
immediately knew something was off and
that was a crazy thing if if all the
different characters that are here are
basically villains playing the role of
superheroes then what does that mean for
the century from there like you pick up
to the like the avengers hideout out in
brooklyn and you basically kind of start
grabbing people snatching them up
bringing them in and they all kind of
just go flying directly into this
conflict you know out into uh to
brockton oklahoma now you do have
like wolverine who shows up and a lot of
the other people who were previously
part of the new avengers roster who are
more or less just kind of the avengers
here now
but in the middle of this this whole
conflict right like when when
wolverine's taken out
you have norman osborne who's almost
taking a little bit of gloating and then
you have tony masters right taskmaster
like i do i love task i love taskmaster
right
best fighter in the entirety of the
marvel you know taskmaster says dude you
might want to turn around
and when he does there's captain america
right just comes comes flying down on
this guy like a bat out of hell and it's
like all these avengers right spider-man
and
everybody just comes on it's a full-on
war now man it's a full-on war right
like the avengers
and against like norman osborne's dark
avengers the whole thing was leading to
this right
the problem is that now the centuries
basically turn right and the question is
how many gods
will i have to kill today so then it
goes into like a full-on fight between
like the century
and thor now here's the crazy thing
about this to give you guys perspective
of the century man that's why this is
why i say man folks man you guys don't
understand you put century in the marvel
cinematic let me tell you something man
let me let me
man let me tell you something okay let
me let me tell you something man like if
you have the sentry
in the mcu he would have wrecked thanos
like that and it wouldn't even been a
con it wouldn't even been
like a fight like it would have been
like a punch and like that would have
been it right thanos would have been out
here's how i know that right like he
goes running up on him with a hammer a
mule
right here he goes running up on him
with mulliner and just like smashes this
guy as hard as he possibly can
he travels like 10 feet and i don't even
mean like he goes flying i mean like his
his feet stay on the ground and he just
like
skids back by like 10 feet and then
that's it right i mean like there's not
a whole lot doing here the only time we
ever really saw anything on this level
was back in the day when
thor threw his hammer at the juggernaut
and it just bounced off of it right
because of his force field
like juggernaut just laughing at him
they just laughing at thor like oh [ __ ]
please like it's
it was a hilarious moment right at that
point norman osborne
starts calling in his reserves throws
essentially all the super villains
against all the superheroes the only one
you're really missing here is iron man
now iron man of course again recovering
from his injuries you got maria hill
who's basically guarding him because he
was essentially taken out speed shows up
with an iron man suit and it's like dude
you gotta get out there man so like
literally iron man
dawns of the iron man suit right at that
point the federal government's like okay
do whatever you have to do take norman
like take hammer down
the orders given like by any means
necessary
and so at that point like the us
military is taken over by the federal
government which normally it would
operate under norman osborn as he needed
it right it's not
it's not one of those things where they
would serve at the pleasure of norman
osborne the president is still the
commander-in-chief right so like the
military still answers to him but in a
lot of ways it would just be lent out to
shield as they would need it at this
point government's like
nope like they're totally they totally
belong to us right like just come flying
in right like these
like these these man these jets just
cruising in right it's just
just firing missiles off all over the
place take down norman osborn's
helicarrier right victoria hand is like
all hands abandon ship right like
everybody everybody bails out then it
comes back down to thor and
end of the century and the problem is
like as thor starts to fight the century
he starts to realize
something's not right here right like
something's off here there's something
going on with this guy
this is not robert reynolds and you're
right thor you're right thor
it is not robert reynolds it is robert
reynolds but it is not the century
son thor is fighting against the void to
give you guys perspective on the void
right to give you guys pressure on the
void there's a few things you need to
know here one the void's the only thing
that the incredible hulk is afraid of
and two there's a what-if story that
exists out there you'll find a link to
it down in the description where the
void killed all the superheroes during
this story in fact and then goes out and
wipes out all the cosmic entities around
the universe and then destroys the
universe right like the void
is just unbridled power right just just
unbridled power
what this means is thor is painfully
outclassed right just
wildly outclassed here as is everybody
right like that's the whole thing like
it's painfully outclassed but at this
moment right now the century is doing
the bidding of norman osborne right
that's kind of what's happening now
norman osmore like with this whole thing
going on captain america is fighting
norman osborne and then in turn
here comes iron man right and the funny
thing is iron man's like that's my suit
that you're wearing and i have backups
for all my suits so understand
this is useless right he literally has a
has a suit of norman osborne completely
shut down
the problem is that as all this is going
on like you literally have
norman osborne who just kind of sends
out just this this last desperation
message right he tells he tells the
century he's like he's like robert right
bob
don't let them win bring it down right
bring the whole
thing down and robert reynolds is like
done right he just
totally collapses the entirety of asgard
right takes out the whole of asgard the
whole thing collapses down in brockton
oklahoma
norman osborne's more or less defeated
right and he's just like you have no
idea what you've done here and they're
like
what are you talking about he's like no
man like he's he's starting to turn back
into the green goblin again right he's
losing his mind he's like you don't know
what you've done like you think you've
done something here
you think you've defeated me you think
the day is over and my forces have lost
not a chance you have no idea what
you've done i'm the only one who could
control him
i'm the only one that could keep him
under control and when thor
asks where's loki right where's my
brother then like the response of norman
is like he's dead
you're all dead everybody here is dead
he's going to kill you all
he's going to kill all of us like i was
trying to save you
i was trying to keep you alive and
that's when you end up finding out
what's going on here is the void has
completely returned taken over the body
of the century let me tell you something
guys
i'm gonna tell you something right now
i'm gonna i'm gonna say i'm i'm man
i'm gonna tell you all something right
now man this is this is a this is a
crazy thing it's a crazy thing
the void man the void
is an absolute demon but you'll have to
wait to find out in the next video
thanks for watching guys
peace